alors nous on va préciser que toi ce que
tu as fait que ton fils hugo qui dans
les coulisses qui est magnifique
t'as pas fait un instagram en son nom
pour vendre des marques en son nom vous
avez créé une marque ensemble c'est ça
qui s'appelle assez les boks voilà les
boks voyez là où est-ce que c'est pas ça
c'est pas un peu la même chose c'est
quelque part est ce qu on joue pas sur
les mots tuent mais quand même ton fils
en avant et tu le mets dans les
publicités avec toi et sur d'instagram
avec toi tu mets ton fils en avance
qu'il écrive à l'école il est reconnu
aujourd'hui c'est déjà une star tu mets
ton fils en avant pour de la vente fait
pas c'est pas vraiment une pub parce que
mon fils maintenant il en a joué à
l'école c'est ckoi par ge et instagram
t'as vu c'est lui qui m'a demandé donc
moins j'ai dit oui parce qu'en fait dans
la rue quand je cachais mon 6 des gens
qui venaient prendre mon fils en photo
et les photos tournai et ça m'énervait
parce que je ne suis pas aussi en fait
c'est chiant parce que moi j'ai une vie
normale je vais me conduire à l'école je
vais à faire des bulles amélie tu l'as
tu l'associé de la vente est ce qu'on
veut dire quelque chose c'est déjà ton
enfance à du marxisme les blocks déjà on
gagne pas d'argent dessus si on donne de
l'argent à une association je ne gagne
pas un bénéfice de malades sur les box
c'est quelque chose que j'ai fait aussi
avec des mamans voilà passe comme ça
voire beaucoup de messages et le retour
et que du positif parce qu'on me dit
merci parce que je vois là j'ai une
activité à faire mon fils adore faire à
manger mon fils adore regarder mon fils
adore manger comme comme tout le monde
je vais dire l'idée ce n'est pas de
protéger ton fils de cette célébrité de
mon ski est protégée de toute façon quoi
qu'il arrive par mois que quelqu'un
s'approche de lui je suis émue anne mais
c'est non parce que c'est moi qui gère
son image
donc je ne vois pas où est le mal c'est
mon site j'ai fait un peu ce que
j'allais craquer dans ces sacs et d'un
casque et d'un garçon livré oui mais oui
dans les chairs son image
pardon alors moi je moi je ne vais pas
me je ne suis pas perd donc je pense que
tu sais parfaitement ce que tu fais avec
ton enfant j'ai juste passé la journée
hier à regarder les rapports de
microsoft de l'om est sur ce genre de
pratique et je ne sais pas si c'est bien
aussi c'est mal je constate qu'elle est
celle là aujourd'hui mais ce que disent
les psychiatres qui parle des enfants
qui sont comme ça ça ça prouve une
fragilité participent des parents avant
tout et surtout ils disent ça risque
avant tout que l'enfant devienne un
adulte qui se rejettent lui-même qui vit
des patients douloureuse parce que son
image de soi est totalement déséquilibré
c'est à dire que plus tard c'est si je
ne publie pas je n'existe pas
le regard de l'autre prime c'est un
jugement permanent et il explique
les enfants aujourd'hui de ce qu'on
appelle les digital natives ce que tu
représentes c'est à dire les gens qui
sont nés et qui est qu'ils pratiquent
énormément les réseaux sociaux en fait
aujourd'hui les enfants eux demandent à
ce que leurs parents les protège te ment
rien de 30% des enfants qui sont pas
encore nés ont une empreinte digitale un
rendement plus que les enfants en bas
âge chez les enfants qui font ou qui
faisait le prochain usine à et qui
courait les castings et des fois qu'ils
étaient refusés des castings et qui est
pareil ça va faire de ça des produits
larsson ne savait d'auto nikon ne savais
pas que tu aies buteur souviens d'un
casting excusez moi là effectivement
excusez moi bien sûr mais moi ça me fait
rigoler parce qu en donne un psychiatre
qu'est ce qu'il va dire oui voilà votre
enfant en moins 2 ans en 2019
à notre époque immédiate et d'or moi je
connais quelqu'un qui fait danser les
études ont été faites sur donne 100 pays
des témoins médium excusez moi mais les
enfants ça fait bizarre je rejoins ce
que vous dites ça fait des années qu'ils
sont exploités dans la pub presse est
lente et l'elysée n'a rien à voir mais
non ils choisissent souvent les amène et
toutes les différences étaient encore
une fois contient un refuge qui est un
troll un test pour l'europe parce qu'ils
gèrent progresser dans l'école
l'arrivée est coûteux ring quand même
que par exemple instagram notamment
arrêté aussi les là et que pour ça parce
qu'un enfant qu'est - like que son
voisin se sentent et du coup mal aimés
dévaloriser est tombé en dépression
ça n'a rien à voir arrêter votre exemple
de 2,2 de carrière ne sont pas là pour
dire attends ils sont faire que la paria
la réalité et il ya les réseaux aimer
les enfants ils savent pas faire la
passe et la droite myriam et mathieu et
sébastien mais moi ce que j'aime pas
dans ça c'est du bon déjà au delà du
fait que le côté mercantile faut revenir
à sa saison quant au clip dessin de
tourneur exactement ce que j'en vois moi
c'est que au delà de voilà de toutes les
deux tous de tout le côté psychologique
que ça peut en mauvais côté
psychologique ça peut engendrer sur les
enfants c'est que quand elles se font du
pognon sur leur faim
je n'envie désolé ça me choque moi j'ai
deux garçons en 57 ans qui adore neo et
soit que je déteste les couleurs mère
elle fait plein de placement de produit
elle se fait de thunes et c'est sur un
large écho évidemment se demande de
faire la même chose
eh ben je suis désolé sa boîte des
digital natives je ne peux pas le faire
parce que déjà j'ai peur pour mes
enfants et de tout ça et en plus je
trouve que sur le principe de se faire
de la tune sur son mode c'est honteux
mais non c'est juste un mot là-dessus
alors moi je n'en sais moi tous gagnent
un peu d'argent qu'un maigre gagnent de
l'argent moi même mais c'est pour les
jeux ne gagne pas de l'argent sur le dos
de mon fils m'a mis là avec toi il pose
avec toi soigner faute au début oui mais
il était pas mon fils qui fait le
classement c'est moi qui fais pas ça
parce que l'on mettait lui a coûté la
vie à l'ewi pas dire ça vous pouvez pas
dire ça à moitié morte et parce que là
on fait un nom en train de mélanger tout
et ça c'est d'être un jour mélange pas
tout toutes les semaines c'est toujours
le même grand succès en photo avec
quelqu'un c'est tout à fait si la
personne vous dire ça on peut pas dire
si ça reste mathieu vous pouvez pas dire
ça je vous expliquais voyez une pub une
pub pour de la lessive vous avez une
femme qu'elle ait fait un bébé
j'espère que le bébé couches de l'argent
pour la pub et c'est bloqué jusqu'à ses
18 ans si on ne réglera espace on ya un
vrai problème dans l'idée l'idée que
juste que tu dis c'est que même si
effectivement appartement qui est
associé avec quelqu'un je dois associés
c'est que tu mets ton fils sur une image
si tu mets ton fils sur l'image c'est
bien qu'il ya un but quand même c'est
qu'ils servent à quelque chose car cette
image
mais quand on est à raison que c'est ma
vie je sais sa vie à l'usiné ont fait
mais oui eh ben si mon fils me dit maman
je ne veux pas j'écoute mon fils mais
mon fils et ma vue dans les télés et
sait qui je suis et abandonner ces voix
là et les legs bonjour il est magnifique
je juge nam nam aujourd'hui jeudi à
maurice quoi qu'il arrive je veux dire
il est je veux dire voilà c'est un
habitant
il était fan de ce que j'allais vers
super bien à l'école il est très
intelligent
elie de potes sale gueule mais un délit
d'intelligence des gens sur les réseaux
sociaux soit gîtes sont pas en capacité
de protéger leurs enfants puisque les
mois mais elle me paraît tout à fait
clair dans sa tête protectrice avec son
fils le gamin n'a pas l'air vont la
perdre tout à l'heure il a pas l'air
débile mais tu perdras répondent de les
prendre pour des les julien est
maintenant temps qu'il en va là qu'on
liquide tiago qu'à huit cent mille
abonnés à deux en avant des jeunes stars
sur les réseaux y avait bien sûr je ne
nie pas tout sébastien magali non mais
il ya un moment on va se demander si
certains couples d'influenceurs comme ça
ne font pas des bébés juste pour l'e3 je
suis bien je suis désolé on line de
parler comme lg pas on est tous mes
tatouages et pas juste du temps en temps
j'ai pas du tout eu lieu n'est pas ces
gens là et non mais regagnait familiale
passe tu sais pas quelle vie au jour le
jour tu sais pas que tu connais plus on
vivait pas parlé du cas car il est censé
pas parler personnellement d'annuler est
allé dit très bien réalité cette erreur
mais on sait déjà mis à mal euro pour 1
euro ce jeu